[Applauso]
vi confesso che sono emozionatissima poi
sono anche la prima e inizieremo
parlando di una cosa leggerissima morte
e lutto ve lo dico già così ci
prepariamo Cercherò di farlo Comunque
con
l'ironia che insomma un po' mi
contraddistingue
una persona che
ha perso una moglie un marito e vedo ma
una persona che ha perso un padre o una
madre
è orfana
Ma come si chiama un genitore che ha
perso un figlio o una figlia
questa domanda
è nella mia testa da circa due anni da
quando è morto quello che era mio marito
io sono una vedova
Ma i suoi genitori che cosa sono
per me è sempre stato confortante avere
le parole per definire le cose
mi aiutano a mettere a fuoco i pensieri
e la realtà
se ho una parola per dirlo quella cosa
esiste
quella cosa prende senso
e
quindi io sono una vedova vedova è una
parola
che ogni tanto è stata anche una gabbia
per me
soprattutto quando magari le persone
vengono da me e mi vogliono insegnare
come devo vivere il mio lutto grazie Il
lutto è mio me lo gestisco io
Ma è una parola
che io ho che posso decidere se usare o
non usare
posso
decidere con chi usarla come usarla
posso scherzarci sopra anche
è una parola che
mi permette di essere irriconoscibile da
parte di altre persone che come me hanno
hanno vissuto la stessa esperienza
immaginate una specie di club della
vedova danza in cui
sorseggiamo Gin tonic e cerchiamo di
fare piani per godersi al massimo quello
che ci resta della nostra vita visto che
ne abbiamo solo una no
e
[Musica]
io ho questa parola a cui mi posso
aggrappare
e
Ma
i genitori di quello che era mio marito
non hanno una parola per per definirlo
per definirsi
le parole
per me sono qualcosa di molto importante
perché
se ho le parole per per definire le cose
quelle cose sostanzialmente esistono
a me però negli ultimi due anni in cui
sono cambiate molte delle mie geografie
emotive e queste geografie emotive
continuano a cambiare
queste parole mi sono mi sono mancate
spesso e
francamente per una logorroica che ha
fatto delle parole anche il proprio
mestiere è
abbastanza fonte di disappunto Ecco ma
Ma come si chiama
una persona che
ha scelto di non avere dei figli con
coscienza con etica
E come si chiama
una persona che
invece quei film Magari li vorrebbe
ma non li può avere magari per motivi di
salute o per impedimenti legali
Come si chiama una persona che non si
identifica completamente ed
esclusivamente nel genere maschile o
completamente ed esclusivamente nel
genere femminile
non va avanti
Come si chiama una relazione che è
romantica ma non è sessuale
o come si chiama una relazione che è
sessuale ma non è romantica
Come si chiama quella famiglia
che si sceglie che è diversa dalla
famiglia biologica e che è diversa dalla
famiglia basata magari su un legame
monogamo
sentimentale romantico ma è altrettanto
importante se non di più
Ecco a me negli ultimi due anni sono
mancate tante parole effettivamente e
però per me è cruciale avere le parole
per per definire le cose e quindi
anche se in italiano quelle parole non
ci sono io ho cercato di inventarle
ho usato delle metafore
ho preso in prestito parole da altre
lingue da altri campi
per me le parole sono importanti perché
mi permettono di trattare con gentilezza
e rispetto tutte le persone
mi permettono di
conoscerle di rispettarle e di conoscere
la loro storia mi permettono di
avvicinarmi a loro e
e quindi
questo per me è veramente
la prima cosa da fare è partire dai nomi
propri
io ho pochissimo a memoria e però cerco
mi sforzo di ricordarmi i nomi delle
persone che mi vengono presentate
anche se sono dei nomi magari che non ho
mai sentito prima e che sono difficili
da pronunciare
sto sto cercando di vendere la mia
macchina da un po' di tempo e
di recente mi ha ricevuto questa
telefonata e insomma questa persona
interessata a comprare la mia macchina
io mi sono messa un po' d'accordo Ok ci
sentiamo ci sentiamo tra un po' però
lasciami il tuo nome così ti salvo in
rubrica e
così ti richiamo
surendra mi ha detto però mi puoi
chiamare Andrea voi in Italia fate
fatica
e io ho pensato a tutte le volte che
ricevo magari un'email che inizia con
ciao Elisa invece che Ciao Elena e
capita molto più spesso di quanto
possiate credere
e ho pensato come mi sento
totalmente invisibile
diamine almeno il mio nome Cerca di non
sbagliare Almeno quello e quindi gli ho
detto surentra se preferisci che ti
chiami su riandrai io ti chiamo così
e ho pensato
alla sottile violenza che surrendra
prova ogni santo giorno Vivendo in
Italia
a parlare con noi che non ci ricordiamo
il suo nome
lui ha scelto di cambiarlo quel nome per
renderci più facile la vita
Io ho pensato ma io sarei disposta a
rinunciare al mio nome per facilitare la
vita di una persona che manco conosco
ecco
le parole
sono
importanti perché ci permettono di
entrare in contatto con l'altra persona
ci permettono di creare una connessione
le parole Poi
sono
collegate strettamente al pensiero e
alla realtà
sono il riflesso di un ideologia
rispecchiano i rapporti di potere e di
classe di una società
il linguaggio non è un semplice mezzo di
comunicazione
Possiamo vederlo anche come uno
strumento potentissimo di manipolazione
della società
ma il linguaggio è anche molto
Democratico letteralmente chiunque lo
usa tutti i santi giorni e quindi
attraverso le parole che sceglie ha il
potere di plasmare
la realtà è il pensiero propri e altrui
il linguaggio Proprio come la realtà è
come il pensiero è imperenne evoluzione
Questo significa che che nascono
costantemente parole nuove
nascono parole nuove tutte le volte per
esempio che
inventiamo un oggetto che prima non
esisteva pensiamo per esempio al
computer o alle automobili prima
nascono parole nuove anche quando
nascono nuovi concetti nuove azioni
come per esempio selfie o scrollare
nascono nuove parole tutte le volte che
nella società ci rendiamo conto che
abbiamo bisogno di adeguare la lingua
per raccontare la nostra realtà per
raccontarci meglio
questo è successo per esempio
con la parola femminicidio che
il secolo scorso quindi poco più di
vent'anni fa non esisteva in italiano
femminicidio è una parola che è stata
usata in ambito giornalistico proprio
all'inizio degli anni 2000 e adesso non
ci ricordiamo più un mondo in cui questa
parola non esiste no tutte tutti noi
sappiamo che femminicidio è
quella violenza nei confronti delle
donne compiuta perché sono donne che può
sfociare anche nell'omicidio
prima che cosa si usava
Si parlava di omicidio molto banalmente
o addirittura di delitto d'onore
cosa è successo la società ha visto un
problema
e quindi
ha deciso di adeguare la lingua
questo è successo anche con un'altra
parola un po' meno famosa ancora però
magari dopo questa sera sarà ancora più
famosa e che è abilismo
abilismo è la discriminazione nei
confronti delle persone con disabilità
Anche questa è stata usata per la prima
volta in ambito giornalistico in
italiano nel 2006
anche se è entrata nel dizionario dei
neologismi di Treccani solamente nel
2022 Grazie anche all'impegno di
attiviste attivisti
con disabilità come Marina cuollo Simone
riflesso Elena Paolini Maria Chiara
Paolini Sofia Righetti
grazie al loro impegno loro si sono
ci hanno fatto vedere che esiste Questa
discriminazione e che quindi noi abbiamo
bisogno di una parola per definirla
nel podcast sulla razza
la dice William goda Maria Catena
Mancuso e Natasha Fernando
parlano di parole che ancora non
esistono in italiano non esistono perché
nella nostra società italiana e
italofona non abbiamo ancora ben
definito i loro referenti Ovvero le cose
a cui queste parole si riferiscono una
di queste parole è colorismo il
colorismo è una forma di discriminazione
nei confronti delle persone con la pelle
molto scura
che subiscono una discriminazione
ulteriore rispetto a persone con la
pelle Comunque non bianca ma più chiara
Ma possiamo vedere la lingua che si
trasforma non solo introducendo delle
parole che prima non esistevano ma anche
vedendo che alcune espressioni o parole
vengono
risomantizzate
Acquisiscono dei significati diversi
nuovi
è il caso dell'espressione color carne
che
Giuditta Rossi e Cristina Maurelli hanno
ci hanno fatto riflettere su questa su
questa espressione che effettivamente è
discriminatoria perché pone la luce
solamente su un tipo di colorazione
della carnagione umana Ma hai tutti gli
altri
la carnagione umana ha infinite
sfumature e noi ce le stavamo
dimenticando
io sono una vedova
e Beh in questo momento effettivamente
il mio privilegio di vedova forse sta
questo privilegio che mi ha permesso di
vivere indisturbata per due anni forse
sta per finire perché la gente sta
ricominciando a chiedermi quando mi
troverò di nuovo un uomo da sposare però
ecco io ho una parola
i genitori che hanno perso un figlio o
una figlia quella parola non ce l'hanno
in italiano in italiano non ce l'abbiamo
in altre lingue Esistono delle
espressioni per definire ad esempio i
genitori che hanno perso un figlio e una
figlia come in tedesco pervais de
heltern
ebraico una famiglia che ha perso un
membro molto giovane della propria
famiglia Insomma
si chiama shakula
in arabo una madre in lutto si chiama
takla
in inglese non esiste una parola ma
Carla Holloway
che ha perso il proprio figlio
proposto di usare viloma che è una
parola che deriva dalla stessa radice
sanscrita da cui deriva anche la parola
vedova
in italiano
perdere un figlio o una figlia è una
cosa talmente spaventosa
che
non abbiamo una parola per definirla
perché se non abbiamo una parola
quella cosa non esiste
O almeno possiamo fingere che non esista
e quindi
adesso Vi propongo
una riflessione
a voi è mai capitato di raccontare
un episodio della vostra vita e di non
avere la parola giusta per farlo
Vi è mai capitato di essere
descritte o descritti da parte di
un'altra persona con una parola che non
avete sentito esattamente come vostra
Vi è mai capitato di provare un'emozione
a un sentimento che non sapevate
nominare
Quali sono le parole che vorreste per
descrivere il mondo in cui volete vivere
o
che Sognate
Grazie
[Applauso]